[Music]
in today's date on your side while
interest rates inflation and other
Financial topics weighing heavily on
many parents shoulders most kids really
don't have a clue what these financial
terms mean and how they can impact their
parents finances a news now anchor
Kirsten Joyce connects with an expert on
why and how to share these things with
your children
[Music]
let's raise rates 10 times since its
first pandemic pandemic in March of
2022. the economy is slowing recession
risks are high investors anticipate the
FED will pause its interest rate hiking
cycle at its next June meeting but is
this all something our kids need to be
following Greg Merced says yes teaching
your kids about things inflation and
interest rates it's all very important
they need to learn that in the context
of overall personal finances we're set
as a parent of six a certified financial
planner and consultant who started the
busy kid app to help his kids and others
learn how money Works he says teaching
your kids the fundamentals of life
skills early lets them practice along
the way things like mortgage payments
interest rate hikes and inflation are
all relevant so be transparent teach
your kids by letting them know how it's
impacting your family point it out when
you go to the gas station it costs more
than it used to to fill up your car
point it out when it costs more for
groceries and basic things like this is
how it will kind of crystallize in their
mind
teaching kids critical Financial skills
at home key to Preparing them for
Success later on in life when they're
young teach them how money comes in give
them chores and responsibility at age
eight to about 13 reinforce a balanced
Financial approach earning saving and
donating and then when they're in high
school you can incorporate investing
teaching about things like investing and
learning to invest and how wow I can I
can not only invest my money and it will
grow but I can also earn things like
dividends and things like that where I'm
actually earning money without even
doing things